[Musique]
la pause
je vais parler un peu de ce que j'ai
fait ce qui lui s'était justifierait que
le sud se positionne aujourd'hui parce
qu'on l'a béni pour moi c'est une
démarche que peu pâti des états
innovation
donc je vais implanter dans les étages
dans le progrès 6 tc canet salinisation
et comment cela peut contribuer au fait
à pourvoir conscrits d'une vente
imminente
cela commence d'abord par la star par
l'observation de nos problèmes
d'aujourd'hui de programmes inédits de
man sont plaints plupart des problèmes
sur le réchauffement climatique
les problèmes d'éducation de problèmes
environnementaux 65 millions d'africains
n'ont pas d'électricité
donc la question que nous pouvons nous
poser est de savoir quelle pourrait être
tel pourrait être le déshonneur notre
mode de fonctionnement comment nous
devons consommer pendant leur marché
comme on nous vend communiqué
globalement comment nous devons
météo fait nos habitudes duvel fait
petite analyse avec vous c'est de
montrer aux fêtes les différents lieux
que l'être humain prétendent nous savons
à domicile nous avons également notre du
travail ou du moins notre but
scolarisation écoles universités et
l'être humain chaque jour 80 au moins 7
des espaces donc l'impression que nous
pouvons nous poser est de savoir quand
un individu est pas rose
nous sommes par exemple dizaine de
personnes qui en hausse et d'une
maîtrise n'arrivons pas aux cycles
supérieurs
donc les autres qui n'allait pas aussi
supérieur quelle est leur descriptif 12
yens soit ils déménagent nouveau chacun
c'est sauve qui peut
donc nous il ya la possibilité de créer
d'autres lieux qui seront à cheval en
soit la maison milieu de travail ou
l'école
donc c'est lui là peut aider à ce que
d'autres personnes qui sont issues que
de résister par l'avantagé système
éducatif ou qui n'ont pas plu à la bible
opus se retrouver et collaborer donc
c'est le lan de sommes en sushi donc
c'est des espaces ouverts à tous pour
tout le monde peut y entrer et paul
arboré avec votre et sonnait donc
faisait face sont souvent disponibles
demain dans nos cantines et tout le
monde fuit présenté dans son épaule des
professionnels on y trouve les étudiants
avaient trop les sans emploi également
donc ce sont des espaces non plus
nation contrats aidés par exemple des
tables à des investissements 2002 crise
donc faisait sans innovation rassemble
des personnes qui travaillent
généralement sur des projets à forte
composante écologique
donc ils peuvent être qualifiés pour par
exemple mieux ou des femmes des jeunes
et aux revenus pour labourer des enfants
en match des programmes scolaires ou des
étudiants majeurs roland scolaire peut
glisser dans ce genre de ne pouvoir
trouver la prolongation et il s'est
déroulé donc les patchs l'état peut en
voir nos différents espaces d'innovation
sur le continent africain sont sous
diverses formes
il y a dans la plupart des capitales
africaines des problématiques sur les
ans du ps l'idée serait par exemple de
démocratie bien que notre bureau d entre
eux qui devaient venir partager dans nos
quartiers à premier dauphin de pauvreté
ou que personne ne m'a bien plus aller
directement dans ses yeux au lieu de
subir les embouteillages pour arriver au
milieu du travail dans l'ain par là qu
on peut profiter à tout péter fischer
une idée pour que ces idées là si ça
marche on peut les prolonger à une
grande
donc dans un faible apport valorise les
riches et pauvres cette imprimante wade
de la main sur une troisième conçu à
partir de gestion informatique donc
quand on lui avait en valais le juger
pour le trouver un nouveau site
d'utilisation
donc les femmes la délicate les flammes
sont de deux sortes de nos laboratoires
ruraux la boîte de recherche et
développement mais qui se trouve sur
notre site la donne est ce que lui
manque la science des personnes y
viennent hélas n'est plus en fait du
mieux university mais également la
recherche scientifique ou ceux pratiqués
dans nos quartiers à partie dès la
récupération que nous allons vers ou à
partir de composants électroniques qui
seront ya une solution plus suisse est
venue étant donné que c'est un mouvement
par une ariane et un faussement la
douleur sur le temps que je vais
partager un petit peu mon esprit
rationnel dans cette aventure c'est en
2014 que nous avons initié que ce n'est
pas la nouvelle qui consiste pour fêtes
a fait des cafés populaires un potentiel
d'innovation technologique ibm ainsi
découvert à nu que nous avons suivi et
c'est là surtout que nous allons de
poubelles concerne une fable en avoir
deux fabricants sont concernées aux
états unis
en europe aux etats unis également et
des françaises sur le continent africain
j'en prends comme un dossier se fasse là
d'avoir la pression que nous sommes
posée quelle pourrait être la réalité de
cette innovation sur le continent
africain particulièrement le trajet des
ivoiriens comme ça comme ça qu'on sait
projet la philosophie du fait d'être
confiné le potentiel pour l'innovation
technologique as tu une idée pour nous
elle contribuer à réduire les disparités
entre populations vis-à-vis pour ceux
qui ont facilement accès à l'outil
numérique et ceux qui m'ont longtemps
pourquoi parce que la plupart de nos
villes africaines les illustrations
david ancien de l'als antoine autres
également des très populaires qui ont
des caractères assez particulier la fois
populaire d'amour de jien est une
commune qui est une autorité publique a
très mauvaise réputation grand
banditisme
un civil niveau de port était assez
élevé donc comment faire pour que
désormais en plus peut paraître ce
phénomène
grandmont ben dis donc c'est comme ça
que nous avons ouvert un espace ouvert à
tous dans la compagnie bal avec l'accord
de la famille sous la terrasse on a une
idée votre laboratoire pour les enfants
à la robotique à l'électronique et
l'informatique ont conduit des projets
d'innovation sociale des opérations de
développement des applications ou des
entités réglementées un modèle de
développement qui passe de 7 à ces
reculs elle a montré qu'elle avait
l'intelligence n'est pas que du positif
nous avons voulu juste retombée ci
s'exécute et qui nous font face à des
opportunités d'affaires
donc ce qui justifie la présence de
notre espace qu'aucune aide à vous
mais comme le comme le montre cette
image le parcours est difficile
non sinon dans un environnement assez
atypique ce temps l'entreprise
quand nous avons initié ce projet on
employait m'approchais demandé au fait
qu'elles sont de manière quelle est la
vision figée ou procéder à une
transformation interne le développement
de l'entreprise donc je lui ai fait pas
de pas mal de propositions et lui
effectué lundi que toute entreprise
mais va pas s'enfermer dans son coeur de
métier maintenant pouvoir crier votre
tranquillité dans ce sens ça que j'ai
exposé cette idée ce pouvoir jouer la
reprise et l'internet à travers l'espace
innovation comme un autre banquier donc
l'apport défensif a été volé mais ma
grave celui du peu dessus je suis arrêté
par la police scientifique du travail et
après je me rends compte que sa plainte
déposée par mois ou concurrence déloyale
je croyais et je ne compterais que la
démarche entre canal que j'ai entamé
était mal fondée par l'ex employeur donc
faire la queue au fret a commencé comme
ça que j'ai quitté le monde de demain
côté douloureusement actuellement
m'engager à l'entrepreneuriat
le pape n'est pas facile certes cela
plutôt projet mon engagement
parce que lorsque des personnes qui nous
mêmes et sur nous tout ce que nous
faisons
on constate de cet exercice c'est de pas
internet que mes droits en météo fait
que le gallon d essence et après jour
des tensions un titre et j'ai retrouvé
la liberté
questionnement dans l'entrepreneuriat
social donc aujourd'hui ça a été plutôt
un moteur pour moi les transformations
individuelles non seulement mais écrire
également dotation de cette ville
populaire populaire qui doivent croire
en eux et à lever la main des résultats
que nous pouvons en bresse présenté et
que dans cette commune populaire la
commune d'abobo
on n'a plus touché depuis deux ans
tranquille des fondamentaux du
commandement des écoles environnantes
dans la halle aux viandes utilisées dans
l'espace comme espace de travail
collaboratif pour leurs étudiants lot
des favoris qui vit dans un espace de
travail collaboratif dans un quartier
peu défendre un projet éducatif qui peut
être un prolongement du système éducatif
faire en sorte que les établissements
qui n'ont pas l'équipement de balai dans
ces lieux et expérimenter la science
populaire enfants qui sont dans les
sentiers plus dans ce genre de programme
ce n'est donc pas grand-chose à fait
peuvent aller apprendre la science suis
cellule donc c'était là aux vêtements
petit estimant que j'aimerais partager
aussi avec un évidement magicien et que
l'afrique est le laboratoire de
recherche et développement des noms
parce que les espaces d'innovation peut
jouer à ce niveau en treize ans vole
parfois y voit par exemple être un pays
à de colle aux dents
région on trouvera des entretiens maison
de production par les hommes du fatah ou
si nous y installons semblables ce fable
à poura provocation de cause des
problèmes des agriculteurs des solutions
pour que les agriculteurs ne puisse plus
être ennuyés par exemple un match et
penser d'un solution donc des étudiants
qui emballe prises deux refusent d'aller
à la terre parce qu'on utilise la
machette su utiliser d'autres moyens qui
vont connaître assure que mais je suis
revenu en avait hélas cette initiative
que ce fait dans les traces blanches
parce que la manif ou d'une intelligence
sa tv talent contre les associés ont
créé ensemble de projets je sais que
l'histoire nous allons démontrer que la
plupart de samedi n'est ce n'est un peu
avant 40 ans ou un peu après donc il
s'entraîne et innovante et de plus si
l'afrique est le continent le plus jeune
du même mois je crois fermement que le
prochain un stage et un africain
la plus grosse thèse la plus grosse
question qui va falloir et zou c'est de
savoir d'où viendra si pour lui prouver
mais en triant les espaces innovation
sociale que sont les laboratoires de
fabrication peut contribuer à tous
prochain à saint affricain que l'afrique
représente à l'argument est à régler
pour que la paix de valablement son
continent et faire en sorte que ces
instants là le chantier l'allemagne l'a
fait que vous êtes fonctionne
[Musique]